i watched mortal kombat last night
anyone seen mortal kombat yet
he has you saw it what do you think
sorry not yet no
i loved it it's good i mean you gotta i
mean it is you know take it for what it
is yeah
it's more combat yeah like if i would
have went to a theater like the took the
fam
got a babysitter and [ __ ] not that kind
of lit
no but for what it is i don't think you
could make mortal kombat like this it's
not for the storyline it's for the
fatalities it's for the blood it's for
the [ __ ] they do a good job like
referencing the video game like the
moves and the fatalities yeah
which i love yeah i grabs a mortal
kombat baby dog
yeah mortal kombats down down stop back
back this is what i want to know you
think when you went to the arcade you
know there's that older dude who was a
beast at
all the games yeah you knew all the
music all the fake tallies where did he
learn
and he was doing it at the art yeah
think about it there's no forums there's
no internet yeah
how the [ __ ] did he figure that out he's
at home
at home when it's loading they they have
like the hit list the list and stuff
like that you can go
back yeah you're supposed to hit like
certain things at the arcade because i
know at home like it's a little bit
easier you can practice
at home you can act there's actually a
fatality mode and they show you how to
do the fatality
well you tell me back in the day there
was no nothing yeah mortal kombat one
there's nothing yeah there was no forum
and he did facebook yeah you just heard
it dude yeah
and even then you'd watch my oh my god
i'm not doing that and you would have to
hit so many
[ __ ] buddies i didn't get in my 30s
that's kind of late
how did they know though how how did
they know how to do them did you ever
think about that they were like damn
right are you late dawg
you know what pissed me off about
fatalities is when you be pressing back
back a b and you get too close
yeah you have to be a certain distance
some guys for a different fatality have
to be really far really close
scorpio that's like yeah you got to stay
in the circle how the [ __ ]
those older vets of the arcade figure i
used to play mortal kombat trilogy which
was on playstation
and it was easier to like i had i had
this code where i could just unlock
everything
to where i would just hit one button
fatalities
that's that cheat code
i used to print my cheat codes out on
the paper and just try to like have it
on my lap and just try to do all uh the
fake
yeah yeah
you do those fatalities that's like
going bottle surface in the club yeah
like it was
lit that's like god damn it was
absolutely the only video game there was
no girls in there but still
almost like damn no like girls oh girls
in the arcade
girls there's nobody you got the right
yeah i got it i got the right
bartender yeah yeah
christian over here walking that mr d's
the movie's good though the movie's
[ __ ]
good i told you yeah for what it is
they try to play scorpion though i don't
like how they try to hold wait so
does it revolt like the old ones they
revolve about lou kang
do they revolve off an individual on
this one well it's a new
scorpion it's a new scorpion like you do
you have yours
yeah yeah have you played the latest
ones and he's like a new yeah
he's a different type you don't you
don't have like the uh
and then i didn't like sub zero with the
shoulder pads yeah i like him
i love him he was a badass but i didn't
like how his shoulder pads went up to
him
he looked like a stingray sub-zero yeah
that just started here i didn't like
that they had shang
and everything oh there's no goat goro
in it
yeah they do yeah that's that's how
sub-zero looked in the movie
no no keep going out do that right right
there right there chin which one oh no
not like
kind of not this one no i wish you
looked like sub-zero
that one was dope that looked hard yeah
he was an injustice the
the injustice game that was fire they
have order combat characters and
injustice
uh a couple of them yeah like uh i'm not
an uh mortal kombat guy but they had
like
uh i think uh raid yeah his name is
no you're too young for mortal kombat uh
like it was when i was when i was like
uh you're born in 98
yeah yeah when i was like 10 to 16
mortal kombat
was like the game that everybody was
like mortal kombat
nba jam madden yup yeah i grew up on
trash bandicoot
i grew up all right it's back doug it is
i downloaded from my son he's like what
is this i'm like what is this crash
bandicoot was actually a really fun one
i like that one dude it's so hard yeah
wait even
even at 38 years old that game is a
beast
no on the on the [ __ ] uh the kids
have the nintendo
switch okay switch the game's legit it's
[ __ ] it's better than the way better
but you forget how hard it is that [ __ ]
they like mario like my son will
dominate mario
crash bandicoot like dad can you beat
this level like bro
let's see that cracker barrel you get
those yeah oh my god i can't play mario
to save my [ __ ] life
really that game is so hard like like
like cars or just
like like uh the [ __ ] the regular
regular regular mario
yeah you know yeah when i was like when
i was in kansas city the comedy
club of kansas city they have uh in the
green room they have
it's set up to where it's awesome you
have all the nintendo games or whatever
those earlier video games you want to
start trying mario and i
bruh it's so [ __ ] hard everybody in
the group was trying
yeah if you have a touch of the downs
it's really difficult
yeah you remember you just have to [ __ ]
with the direction hit the a button and
jump over mushrooms
[Applause]
it takes me a while to figure out levels
a lot of days
there's no no when i beat it uh like
tiger go to bed and then
his mom will fall asleep and i'm like
let me figure this [ __ ] level out
dude i'm up
ours tiger wake up i'm like wake up dog
yeah like six hours wake up dog
i beat that leg to the next level yeah
yeah
you got that here we go damn you
remember spyro the dragon remember that
one uh
no that uh purple that little purple
dragon that was hard oh yeah yeah i
didn't play that
one but i know the game yeah it was hard
there's also you know you're way too
young for you
donkey kong no donkey kong 64 was lit as
fast it was hard oh yeah that right
there
i remember spyro but there was um what
double
golden eye goal
come on yeah i'd be odd job so it's real
low and the
the gun would miss you that's the key
when you used to play multiplayer that
game was lit as [ __ ]
yeah where's muscle playing game yeah
yeah have you guys ever played uh
castlevania contra who daft jam
jeff jackson oh my god yeah no fight for
new york is the best one
yeah wait hold on
the fight that's what you're doing fight
night new york is the best one they have
all the rappers in it what are you
talking about
fight gaming could be dmx yeah ludacris
yep icon was trash though fjm icon was
awful
i haven't remember that remember 50 cent
had a game uh get rich and die trying
to you had to yeah do all like some good
stuff i actually bought the game my boy
my boy was at um goodwill and he saw it
for like
five dollars and he bought it that makes
sense the game was like terrible but it
was like dope at the same time because
it was like 50 cents
it was like he was like in the middle of
the year it was [ __ ] that he would
think you played nfl blitz
i'm a hockey kid i played nhl 2003 hits
those are fun
me and my brothers we'd be on the same
team we'll just light the scoreboard up
yeah
and rugby yeah that's funny i never
played the nfl
i actually no i think i did play you've
never gotten to madden or blitz i played
madden a couple times i think i played
blitz when i was younger yeah and ricky
williams on the front cover and cordell
stewart yeah i played i like i said i
played like from
nhl 2003 i i have from nhl 2003 to nhl
201 did they have any version of like
the
blitz or nba street for nhl yeah they
had the 2003
hits they had on and is that like three
on three it's
they have like a whole like three on
three like like in the newest one they
have like a three on three like online
mode where it's basically men's week
where it's it's like three and three
like it's an empty rank it's so much fun
but yeah
2003 hits was like it was just
ridiculous you
run into someone the guy does a backflip
like it was like roller hockey
it was so fun your guy catches on fire
if you're starting to like
would you just go to arcades
how much older you think i am i just had
44. i played all the same games you know
remember shinobi
no ninja stars oh you remember ninja
gaiden
uh yeah yeah i played all those
he's a 2k legend oh yeah i mean he'll
get downloaded nfl 2k
no nba hey ask jay
ask your [ __ ] friend jay how i was at
nfl 2k
i no i'm not even exaggerating dog
i never lost you you know who jake's
friends would come over and i beat the
[ __ ] out i know who you
know i do i would be dante culpepper i'd
be minnesota vikings
and randy moss and i had a play that was
unstoppable i could backtrack
30 yards and hail man throw a bomb
directing my i'm talking i
i beat all of jay's older friends every
[ __ ] time
i'm telling i know someone you can't
beat chad john snoop dogg
who's the killer no he's talking about
nfl 2k that you talking about madden
oh man yeah i was pretty good at madame
but
yeah i thought that was the one that
snoop dogg was playing nah nah
uh he played madden no nba these fans
know i'll be bodying all these fans
are you online online yeah rolly boy
yeah i'm telling you he he
he's nice on the stage i haven't lost a
2k yeah i'm nice in nba too
yeah you grown man now though and i was
uh i'm talking i was a teenager
yeah i was a teenager
no no because you can tell like in the
lobby how to uh message you
uh did you have like an art like i
remember my arcade in aurora
it's actually right next to where the
shooting uh happened was
called aladdin's arcade my mom would
drop can't do this
i'd never do this with my kids my mom
would drop us off there in the summer
gives each 20 bucks
we were there from 9 00 a.m to 5 00 p.m
that was our daycare yeah and i just
watched the old heads with their
fatalities
yeah they don't work like that no more
no you can't do that anymore you can't
just drop no mother everything's online
now
here's what's interesting as a parent if
you look up the stats it was it's more
dangerous
now than it is back then like we think
back then was all crazy yeah
now is way more dangerous i don't even
think kids walk to school even if
there's schools i never let my kid walk
to school
damn because we're aware of everything
now yeah
that's going to be a far-ass walkway oh
yeah hours
oh no okay yeah ours was like a
10-minute walk
but we also stayed outside all the time
like we like
i mean we play video games but we we're
outside all
[ __ ] outside was so funny like when
the street lights turned on we were like
all right better get going that was like
the
that was the thing that was the thing
they really aren't latch key kids
anymore
what do you mean latch key kids
basically that like you come home from
school and then your parents are at work
and you just kind of take care of
yourself
you're at the park you're indoors you
just take care of yourself until your
parents get home at like six or seven
you know
social media on their phones and [ __ ]
everybody
cbs can find out you know what i mean
like if if the kid's like filming
himself at home like yeah i'm chilling
chilling
cps is a [ __ ] hey online yeah cps
online
they be lurking more of the story is
mortal kombat's worth the watch
yeah more yeah especially if you're a
mortal kombat head like me and like my
girl didn't grow up on mortal kombat
so any no she did because any time a
character pop up i'd be like oh that's
raiden or that's you know kane and i'd
give her the backstory
that's sonia did you like liu kang in
there no thank you
why was he such an idiot bro i don't
know the whole vibe bro he messed the
whole thing up
he was getting his ass beat he never won
thank you he was like you you always
just get [ __ ] on and that's what i was
telling
cause the the first uh the first the
first one it was his journey he was your
heart yeah he was like i told my girl
because she was like because my girl
goes i can't stand that kane guy went
it's weird how they're doing them
because i do right this is a dope
character he's a beast
that's the original bro hey listen oh no
i'm uh bringing up
kano oh i kind of
i couldn't stand him in the movie you
didn't like kano no he was annoying he
was the that's
he he was like that and we're gonna
pretend sonia could beat him up like
that how long were you
she beat him up
i sure as [ __ ] don't believe in 2021 no
matter what the left of you're looking
hey look at the first one i go to a
picture uh wait which is the new
cano that that's the o right that's the
og one that's a new one
oh sonya kicks his ass on the right what
does sonia look like in this one
oh she bad she better pretty bad yeah
she's bad yeah is this whole movie just
them
fighting the entire thing yeah yeah
literally just at one people nature they
try to give you like some story and
i told my girl like god they need to
quit trying to paint a narrative just
[ __ ] kill each other it's just
literally just a whole two hours of just
two people fighting yeah that's great
but that's what i want from motor combat
me too yeah i don't want to stop no i
don't know i don't i'm not i mean
oh that's the new sonia yeah i don't
even know scorpion
and all that [ __ ] look at that kill each
other click on the picture
yeah right there also the original is
batter like she was a baddie in the
original
you remember the street fighter movie
with john van damme that [ __ ] was lit
i remember that one they said he was
coked out on that film oh yeah
yeah he admits it oh he does yeah i'm
pretty sure he does and who's better
street fighter characters are mortal
kombat because remember that was always
the street fighter they're not as like
brutal as a
mortal kombat moral combat is just
[ __ ] talk there's a scene in that
where the fatality the girl with the
wings
and he gets on her back oh he get
through his hat and cuts her in half
that was hard that was hard
and he like i gotta watch it after this
that was luke and cousin what was his
name
uh i forget that's what he's being
messed up
yeah took his [ __ ] soul so oh you
know what i was i was trying to compare
i'm sorry
tekken versus uh oh yeah it was much
more that was hard
where the guy with that he had like a
tiger hat on him you're the tekken
characters
oh he uh he had like he had like a tiger
i thought
oh i don't remember still mortal kombat
more combat versus everybody
over two yeah that guy that guy yeah
that guy he was my favorite
he was he was like one of the guys you
had to unlock though right yeah dog i
use the
i like to use the guy that eddie yeah no
the guy that they used was similar to
the
uh to bruce lee uh uh oh i know you're
talking second characters yeah he's
attacking characters
jen but i'd say mortal kombat everybody
but that's why i love street fighter he
loves street fighter
this game at the arcade you talk about
rk's yeah [ __ ] was lit
slim did y'all ever play killer ins this
one was hard though i know it was
a young kid this was hard but again bro
those levels i'm not talking mario hard
yeah
hey
yeah you weren't here cat but i can't
play mario you can't play mario
mario marshall the the one where he runs
straight just regular marcus
like the og like donkey kong's throwing
the barrel yeah my son beat that game
hey [ __ ] adventures
you beat all of them uh did you ever
play killer instinct
what's that i have to see it oh all
right i guess that was just me
that was on super nintendo played at
home i got it on gamecast or something
i ain't got it i never played killer
easter you never played killer oh i have
yeah because i
remember the wolf i always liked the
yeah that game was this [ __ ]
tough to break in that market when you
got street fighter and i know yeah
mortal kombat
that was so good more i'd say more that
goes mortal kombat street fighter
i'll give you that no i got motorcycles
oh really
really i love streaming over street
fighter yeah
tekken are you serious oh like what are
your shots what are we what are we
engaging off of like the characters are
just a game
fun fact yeah the characters yeah like i
like i'm familiar with street fighter
and mortal kombat world combat's less
yeah
like no no no let's say i got it i want
to combat out of it i'm talking about
street fighter versus street fighter
street fighter
with the hair oh he looks like oh oh
that's uh uh ballarog
or barack obama
no you're right barack is street fighter
there he is right there no go
over to john and bison blanca
baraka is uh mortal kombat he's to do
with the [ __ ] sword arms
yeah yeah yeah bro yeah brock is the guy
with me and the teeth
yeah that's what you all thought was all
right
oh yeah right bull right here
bro i used to beat the [ __ ] out of here
remember that tyson knockout what mike
tyson
oh he had a game that was hard lewis had
a game too remember that he did
he did i thought
i thought i was learning close boxing
video game let's see
heavyweight champion boxing there it is
and it just came out it was like a fight
night night
2004 uh knocked out knockout kings yeah
that was the main guy yeah the game was
[ __ ] tough
i thought that was based off of ali man
am i tripping kids ain't trying to play
muhammad ali games
oh look at those graphics those are hard
yeah that was a great game
damn oh wow tyson fury versus hey uh
how was tyson's favorite been in the
game fight night used to be a hard night
oh my god they need to come back with
that fight night have you played the ufc
game yeah i played it it's legit
especially the new one your boy was a
unlocked unlockable
downloaded character in the huge game
yep really yeah you wanted
yep i played the [ __ ]
so what they had to do you had to
complete the story mode i don't know i
was like a downloadable character if you
you did something damn i think i have
ufc one so i'm gonna look i know i
played it i played that was hard i was
like
they tried to compare to fight night so
i'm gonna
yeah i got in trouble because i wasn't
on the original roster for
and then they had me doing this
marketing and i went on the podcast
firing the kid and i
talked [ __ ] about ea sports and oh the
ufc did not like that
all right oh [ __ ] what are you saying
about ea sports i know can you say it
they're the reason they put me in it
they like i was like [ __ ] like i
basically said [ __ ] yeah sports i got a
lot of trouble
i was working for the man at the time um
ea sport
to be fair ea sports is not all they
they down now
what they have don't they they still
produce uh that's it wait so who
produces the uh
they have madden they have uh nba live
they
nba the the the new nba game the one
that you play
sports mallet yeah nba 2k that's they're
not without they have ufc they have
madden their fifa
that's it right and then we don't no one
plays nba live
and it's just
street [ __ ] yeah they have a new version
of that i download it from my son
they do yeah and they have michael
jordan in the game they have you can get
all the
like old school players offering a
street yeah
so it's i think it's two on two it might
be yeah it's two on two because it was
all [ __ ] great yeah that's hard like
i was michael jordan and dennis rodman
and you play this all on your nintendo
yeah okay yeah i'm about to go it's
great
you should get it what's dope is you
just download the game you don't have to
buy the game anymore
you just download the game like when new
game comes out like
35 or something just downloading like an
old or like on a
just one console yeah like we have like
10 games we have mortal kombat on there
and then also like what's dope is they
do updates so like a mortal kombat have
like
sylvester stallone robocop yeah joker's
on there now
so you uh so you don't have to go get
physically getting nice
just downloading it yeah yeah yeah yeah
no no no gamestop is killing it now
because of the whole stocks it's back
but it's not necessarily like people are
going in there to buy video games
i was confused what's ridiculous now is
if you buy the game
you still have to down like if you buy
the physical game
like uh xbox 360 you buy the game you
put it in you can play
you xbox one you go you buy the game you
have to download it and it's going to be
so dumb that's like renting like
minecraft well i like there are certain
games that i buy the
buy the game for because a guy like like
nhl for example like
from 2000 like eight honestly i like how
the case
yeah this is a classic yeah you have
that yeah and well and the call of
duty's too i mean those are
five i have those yeah i can't play
those games make me sick
no call of duty yeah cause all the
[ __ ] running around and i just yeah
after a while you're too much cardio
[ __ ]
no it just it makes me dizzy
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son